(audience cheering)
- All right.
And in an honor of
Teacher Appreciation Day
we've invited an audience
full of students and teachers
to hang out with the cast.
That video was of Marianne
who is here with her
teacher, Miss Mulvany.
So, was there a teacher who
had a big impact on your lives?
I know we all probably had a teacher that-
- I must say.
You're probably still having teachers.
(all laughing)
That are really big impacts in your life.
That's so crazy, I'm old.
(laughing)
So, did you have one?
- I did, yes. Well many, but,
Martin Tyrrell was a
fantastic English teacher
and drama teacher, director of lots
of our shows and just was extraordinary.
I had an amazing art teacher
who said, "You're quite good at art"
and then, you know,
kind of fostered my talent
and made me really believe in it
to the point I got an art scholarship
to the school I was then graduating to.
- Wow.
- Having not been good at art at all.
He just saw something
in me and encouraged it
which I think is what great teachers do.
- Yeah.
- And they can channel a child's energy
into something productive and something
that gives you security
and a sense of identity
and belonging
- Confidence.
- and it's wonderful.
- Yeah.
- Teachers are the best.
- They see that flicker
and turn it into a flame.
It's like-
- That's right, that is it.
- Yeah, I agree. That
happened with me as well.
What about you Benedict W?
(laughing)
- Thank you.
It was brother Joseph
at Sixth Form College
I used to go to,
and,
yeah, we were just in English
and it was the "Friends,
Romans, Countrymen" speech
and everyone was passing
it around, reading it
and people were laughing
and it was my turn.
I think he stopped the classman,
"Everybody just pay attention."
I was just like, carried on
and as you say, he sort of
found the spark really,
that I never knew I had.
- It's empowering.
- Yeah.
- Here I am. (laughing)
- Do you feel like it
changed your personalities?
I feel like it changed mine.
Like I, once I found like music,
like I love singing and
writing and all that.
It changed my personality.
Do you feel like that happened with y'all?
- Yeah, it's wonderful,
isn't it?
- Yeah.
- I mean, just to find the,
just to cultivate as many opportunities
as we can have to see, you know,
what we can lean into.
- Progress.
- Yeah.
- Find what resonates with us all and-
- It's exciting and never stop doing that
until you die.
- No.
- Yeah.
- Mm hm.
- Well said.
- Yeah.
- What about you?
So you have a teacher currently.
Yeah. (laughing)
- Well,
my Wushu teacher,
he's like my coach, Matthew Osborne.
He's been my martial
arts coach since I was 12
and now I'm halfway to my black belt
which is like a really big deal for me.
- Wow.
- And that's also very handy
- Yeah.
- for your character probably.
- That's amazing.
(audience applauding)
- And then, you know,
he's very kind of tough on me, you know,
keeps me patient and, you know, humble,
but he's very charismatic
and funny and, you know,
that's what makes him such a good teacher.
It makes me like want to do better
and actually, you know, continue,
cuz if I didn't, I mean,
he would let me know.
(laughing)